こんにちは
あごめんえっとこれかなこれ皆さんどこの光景だと思いますあのちょっと儲けてるんで
わかりにくいかもしれないですけど
そう品川駅のゾンビ軍団です
5階の新幹線に乗るときにしかこの光景にあの
光景にではないんですけれどもこれを見てはすげえなこの人達っていう風にいつも持っ
ていて動かずとこの人たちとは違う人生をいっぱい生んできましたが
瞼6枚ネーション34階ぐらいしか乗ったことがないんですけど若い時からいつも二十
何年間東京に来て27年間でありますけれどもこういった
満員電車にのって大変そうだ何との人たちがどうしてその僕の側に来ないのかっていう
ことずっと不思議に思ってたんですけども
まあその法則について僕なりに考えてみてどうやったら彼らが
このなんか速ゾンビ軍団から抜け出して自分らしい人生を送れるのかなということを
いろいろ研究してみました
そして
まあこういう結論に達しました
転載純いますバッカー
まあ天才とバカは紙一重という言葉が日本にはあります
まさにそのとおりでじつはうまくいってる人っていうのは天才か馬鹿なんですよ
僕の周りにいる大成功している社長さん
まあ9割がたバカです
まあ馬鹿と天才は紙一重ですから a
天才だと自分を持っている人も実はバカだったりす
これ何なのかというとあの馬鹿っていうのはそのリスクを考え
将来には必ずリスクがある
ゼロリスク進行という言葉がありますけど原発事故だったりとかいろんなことでみんな
0 c 0リスク振興についてすごく
0リス空を
ゼロリスクを求める人達っていうのは原子力発電所問題に対してすごく敏感だし
そういった傾向がありますまあこのへんつまり墓の人達っていうのはまあ
ゼリー作った夜中にありえないのでそのありえないことは知らないんだけれども
とりあえずちょっとリスクがあっても突き進んでみようという人たちですね
でも一番ダメなのはこれも僕がよく入っている言葉なんですけど
こりこ
ポリ公がものすごくダメなんです
でも世の中の大半の人たちは小利口です
だからうまくいかないんです
これをなんとかこのポリ公の人たちが
まあとりあえずはバカになれる仕組みをつくってみたいなというふうに思いました
その前に前段として
皆さんがいかに常識に縛られているのかという話をしたいと思います人生にかかる4台
コストよく
バカになる2
バカになるためには
いろんな物を捨てなければいけないんですけれども
実は我々ものすごい人生の中でコストを使ってます人生にかかる
4台コストなんですけれども次のスライドが出てこないぞ
まず
家族
家族を持つと大体園1勝で6500万円かかるそうです
そして家持つ等6千万円かかります
そして自動車これはあの何回も買い替えたりするんで維持コストとかけると
4200万円そうして
結婚に
550万円かかる
これまあ実はこれしかも日本人60万人結婚するんですけど年間20万人くらい日本し
てますんで
+離婚費用がかかると財産分与であったりとか
婚姻費用とがかかります
これが実は1億7201多く7250万円かかっている
これは実話だから僕は今どういう状況になるかというと結婚まあ1回したんですけど
やめましたリコ
したそして子供は枚一人いるんですけれども良いクハラってますがそれ以上子供いない
で家はないんですね
いい
映画ないどころか僕賃貸もしてないのでほどに住んでいます
そして
車持ってませんそうするとこの日様がゼロになるとこれはすごく極端な例ですけれども
このうちの一つだけでもいや本当に家が好きとか本当に子供が好きとかだったら別です
けど僕いろいろヒアリングした結果
いや俺別に家なんか本当はいらないんだよなぁとか結婚を出したくないんだよなーと
かっていう人結構います
こういった人たち
はまずこういうことを1回考えましょう周りがやってるから
あの俺もいいが欲しいとか車が欲しいじゃなくて1回考えましょうということです
こういったことですねこれは極端な話ですけれども僕はこれまで
たくさんの本
186万円186点2万本も出てるらしいです
うちのスタッフがあの数えてくれました
そしてメールマガジン毎月だしているフリだ髪のブログでは言えない話っていうので
1万6000人の会員がいてここにずっと
発信し続けておきました
ですが残念なことにこのポリ公からバカになるプロセスを実際に実行した人っていうの
は全体のもう
多く見積もっても数パーセントしか言いませんでしたこれはまずいということで私は
新しい組織をつくりましたこれが負0だがみーノベーション大学校という
魔王ラインサロンですで会員過ごす今840円
います
この人たちに僕は何やっているかと言うとただ背中を押すことです
僕のメールマガジンとか僕の本を読んで僕の考え方に共鳴している人たちが842集め
てきて彼らはなんと月1万円払っていますここはポイントですつき1枚を覚えておいて
ください
これはどういうことかと言いますとですねー
くださいこれか
映像が積んでいかない
これまで僕たちは大学に行って就職をするという
だいたいそういう子利口な人たちはだいたいそういうルート
あゆみますこれはどういうことかってこれグラフにするとすごくわかりやすいんです
けれどもこの赤の部分ですね
マイナスですこれ学費ですつまり大学に行っている時は大体日本人は私立大学に行くと
月10万円くらいの学費を払っていますなのにも関わらず
まぁだいたい22歳ぐらいで就職
いるんですけどいきなり20万円くらい給料をもらえるようになるんです
これすごくおかしくないですかよく考えたらだって
大学4年の3月までは月
月10万円ずつはらきたのにいきなり
次の4月から20万円ずつもないですこのギャップ
最低でも30万円ぐらいあるんですね
これって僕すごく変なんじゃないかと思ったんです
まあこれ日本の宝
就職一括ま就職活動だったりとか
新卒一括採用制度とかそういったものの問題点もあるんですけど
パフォーマンス十勝はいきなりじゃあ22歳でいきなり320万円もよプラス30万円
になるようなパフォーマンスが挙げられると言ったらそんなことはないでしょう
次いきます
これを僕たちはすごく平準化しているんですねここ
これちょっとぐらいわかりにくいですけど1万円です
僕たちは別にへ
大学生だろうが子供だろうが大人だろうがみんな1万円です
1万円さえ払ってくれれば何やってもいいよと
で僕たちもそういった僕も何かを教えるし背中を押すしいっていうようなことをやって
います
で1万円を払ってるから
どういうことになるかというと
やりたくないことをやる必要が
次のそれで来ないぞやりたくないことをやる必要がなくなるんですというのは会社に
入ってると
じゃあ月々20万円もらってたら社員はまあもちろんやりたいこともできるんだけど
やりたくないこともやりたくないことをやらなきゃいけないんです
逆に僕は雇ってるがーだとするとその社員たちを宿る魂
に時には儲かってるときはいいんですけど時にはやりたくない仕事もやって社員たちを
食わせなきゃいけないんです
だけれどもこのオンラインサロン上では1万円払ってるからやりたくないことがあった
やらなくていいんですよ
そこがポイントで
そうなるといろんなことを
みなさんが好きなことをやり始めますこれはあのすごく代表的な事例でオーター
サバイバルゲームとか
japan ドローン racing association ってまぁ日本
ドローンレース今日買ったうちのサロンからあのでたんですけどまぁ
こんな感じでどんどんどんどん新しいプロジェクトがたくさん生まれてきています
そういったことが自主的に皆さんやるようになってくるとこれ大学でも教えてくれない
し
自分でやりたいんだいつまりだからなんかすごいいろんなキャップがあるのです
日本の大学って
すごくその実用的に役立つことをから乖離していることをすごくたくさんやっていると
いうことがすごくわかります
そしてうちのオンラインサロンでは民主主義を否定していると僕という独裁者が一人い
て
まあだからなんか神がボールのリークワインを見たいと思うんですけど
舞楽をやってあのはこれはいいねとか僕の考え方に吸わないことはこれはちょっと違う
んじゃないかというようなことをやってます
まあその結果僕が一人いて
これオンラインサロンの特徴なんですけどたくさんの人たちを誘導することが可能です
その結果どうなるかというとまぁこんな笑顔になりましさっきの
品川駅のゾンビの風景ではなくなりますこういったことを今
たったの840人で
やってるんですけれども僕はこんなこの仲間が僕が増えてほしいと思っています
10万人とか100万になると日本のあの品川駅の風景っていうのはガラッと変わるん
じゃないかなと思います
そういった未来を皆さんと一緒に作っていきたいなと思ってこういったこと活動してい
ますので僕の活動これからも落ちてくださいそして日本の風景っていうのを
あるいは世界の風景っていうの大きく一変させるようなことをやっていきたいなと思っ
ています
今日はどうもありがとうございました